la première décision c'est mettre en
mouvement les services municipaux pour
pouvoir accueillir tous les enfants à la
restauration scolaire à la cantine
scolaire à la rentrée 2009 1 et c'est
une gageure mais je veux relever le défi
c'est l'expérience c'est un engagement
écologiste depuis 30 ans et le fait
d'avoir été dans l'ensemble des
collectivités d'avoir une expérience
nationale des réseaux une expérience
très concrète très pratique de la vie en
collectivité la vie locale et bien
connaître le territoire et d'être
soutenu par bon nombre de maires de la
périphérie de besançon d'être connue
peut-être parce que quand on est connu
forcément on connaît les défauts connais
les qualités
c'est ce que je dis souvent avec moi au
moins vous savez à qui vous avez affaire
donc on connaît mes défauts on connaît
mais mes qualités et peut-être aussi
qu'on m'assimile un peu trop facilement
à la politique nationale
un maire engagé un travailleur est
engagé